Never fear!
Minto is here!
Hey party people!
Hello, hello, hello!
Welcome back!
I'm back!
Welcome, welcome back to Metal Gear Solid 4!
Oh, Spank!
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
You're so quick!
We just started!
Thank you!
The frills are back.
And they're back to stay, baby!
They're back to stay!
Hi!
It's like a red dress.
Wait, ask, does JPEGDog help you make it?
Damn!
Thank you for 20 gifted too!
Thank you!
Guys, I have a confession to make.
I have a confession to make.
I...
I didn't think it would cause such a ruckus.
I thought that maybe...
People would be like...
Oh Minto, you're so silly!
With your silly idea, you...
I thought that maybe...
People would be like...
Oh you!
And then we all move on.
Senflex, thank you for the 20 gifted!
Welcome to Bamboo Ship!
Thank you!
And I thought that it would just be...
Here, hold on.
Oh, game.
Oh, game, oh, game.
Oh, game, oh, game, oh, game.
Cute girl.
But, what makes... Wait, what, what, what?
A bit dim.
But that makes it cuter.
Dim?
The lighting?
Okay.
Like in a club?
Wait, the jazz club?
Mint became JPEG dog himself.
That's the inspiration.
But, so for those who don't know what I'm talking about...
I wore a specific dress...
During my jazz karaoke...
Live stream...
And, so if you didn't watch that, you could see it there...
But then some people...
My art tag got completely overrun!
Completely!
Completely taken over!
And I'm very embarrassed about it.
So...
Hold on, let me adjust my chair.
I changed...
There we go.
I'm very embarrassed about it.
I can't even look at my art tag.
I'm so, I'm so, I'm so embarrassed.
My lawyer is still asking when the first child support payment is coming.
We got to see Minto's high D!
Literally everybody opening...
I thought people, honestly, at first I was like...
They might think it's the lighting, I don't think people will notice.
Everybody opening the stream...
High D!
Specific dress?
Jazz karaoke.
Said like Snake.
But um...
Todd!
Thank you!
Today is 6 months since the first time you ever haunted me when you sang at AniRevo 2024!
Which is also coincidentally my birthday!
To commemorate this occasion, could you please sing me a happy half birth...
Half birthday?
Oh.
Half birthday.
Do I sing you half the song?
But if it's MGS style, I guess that is on...
That is a...
On brand, right?
For the...
For the stream today.
Happy birthday!
Congratulations!
Every other word!
Wait, let me see if I can...
Hold on, let me see if I can do that.
Hold on.
I have to look up the lyrics though.
We're doing a half birthday.
Okay.
Wait, but then I only say happy.
But actually that works because I don't say happy birthday.
Because it's not your birthday!
Okay.
Happy...
Congratulations...
With...
Happy...
And...
Your...
Stay...
Happy...
To...
Talk...
And...
The song...
We're talking about birthdays.
Mine was yesterday.
Oh no, I'm sorry!
I couldn't sing happy birthday on your actual birthday, but let's just pretend it's yesterday.
Except I don't want to really do yesterday again.
Long story short, I really don't want to get into it because it was a lot of drama.
My grandma wasn't doing so hot.
And I took her to the hospital.
My mom was out of town.
So I was the only one who could go.
I waited like four hours for an ambulance.
It was like a big...
She was back.
Hopefully things are okay.
Um...
But yeah, so...
There's a whole lot of other stuff involved.
But sorry that I couldn't stream Metal Gear yesterday.
For Lifeline, I'll just bump it to tomorrow as well.
Yeah, it was a long time.
I was like, oh gosh.
I won't be able to stream.
I feel like I could have probably streamed.
Because I was waiting for so long.
But you know, it is what it is.
What was it?
Oh, Bionic Hippo.
Happy birthday.
Congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday.
May your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday Bionic Hippo!
To be fair, it was a cute dress.
But there was a bit.
Singing was already a treat.
Not sure what Wisps did to be spoiled.
But thanks anyway, boss.
You guys spoil me, I feel.
Maybe once in a while I should return the favor.
Maybe sometimes.
I don't know.
Sometimes if you're good, right?
Whatever.
Only once in a while, so you don't get big heads.
So you don't...
Okay, we'll get into the game.
Sorry, I know I'm not stalling or anything.
It's just because I didn't stream yesterday.
I'm all pent up of yapping energy, you know?
Yapping energy, you know?
So many birthdays!
Wait, today is the owl, isn't it?
Oh my gosh.
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the Haka Super!
Today is a special day.
Not only is it my 30th birthday, but there is something else more important.
That's right, the eagles are playing in the Super Bowl!
Can I get...
I forgot that the owl is today.
I don't know if I can say it.
Oh wait, I already said it.
I don't know.
Who is it?
The eagles?
Oh wait, my dad loved the eagles.
Go eagles!
Go!
Kaka!
Go birds!
I think that was my dad's team, the eels.
Wait, is that a team?
No, the eagles.
Kaka!
I'm just confused.
Is it the eagles or the owls?
Great question.
Because... and also there was... I have to sing happy birthdays.
I have to sing happy birthdays.
I haven't forgotten.
Kiara has her wawas, Minto has her...
No.
I do have toes.
Otherwise I wouldn't be able to stand up.
People call it the superb owl because apparently if you say Superbowl on like the radio or on TV or something, they'll find you.
They'll be like, that's our copyright.
And so they'll be like, you have to pay us money if you say Superbowl.
So people scoot the bee over and they say superb owl.
You said it twice.
This is... Good thing this is not live television.
Good thing this is prerecorded.
Okay, I have some birthdays.
Happy birthday!
Sorry, everybody will have a Metal Gear themed birthday song today.
Don't worry, I haven't forgotten about you.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday...
Happy birthday, congratulations.
Happy birthday with salutations.
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
Thank you for being so patient.
Thank you.
You can say it so you aren't part of the system?
Yeah.
Superbowl.
Anyway.
Yes.
Happy birthday to everybody.
Sorry if I missed your birthday yesterday when I was supposed to stream and if you were looking forward to it.
I'm so sorry.
But I'm glad I could sing it for you today.
We're back with Metal Gear Solid 4.
We're on act 3, baby.
This one is a bit silly of a mission we have going on.
And...
Oh!
I forgot to say.
Caprice no!
Thanks for the bangin' I got a new...
Piercing?
Last week.
That is... Wait, it's his birthday.
What is that?
A new what?
A horse?
I'm going to go now because...
A horsey?
A horse.
Happy birthday.
Horse?
Happy birthday to the horse.
Ink voice.
Welcome.
Thank you for the bread.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the 20 gift cards.
We're right back.
Thank you for the gift cards.
Welcome, welcome.
We're just getting started with Metal Gear Solid 4.
But this is act 3 so it's kind of in the middle of it.
Buns of the Metal Gear Solid.
Buns of the Patriots.
Yeah.
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Who are you rooting for in the Puppy Bowl?
Oh my gosh, I was just thinking about Puppy Bowl yesterday actually because...
I don't watch the Puppy Bowl but I know what they did last year.
Do you guys know what the Puppy Bowl did last year?
It was so messed up.
So basically they brought out this tiny little teacup puppy.
He's like 1 pound.
He's the smallest, cutest little puppy ever.
He's like the little tiniest little...
And they show him running around.
They're like, look how much fun this little tiny adorable little baby teacup puppy is.
And they made all of the American population fall in love with this little puppy.
And then...
And then they were like...
At the end of it they were like...
In memoriam.
Oh my gosh.
No!
That's so mean.
I know, right?
Yes, Sweet Pea.
Sweet Pea was the dog's name.
And so everyone's gonna be like, oh my gosh, Sweet Pea.
I fell in love, instant love with Sweet Pea.
But, you know, honestly...
I'm kind of like...
I'm very... I'm very protective of animals.
Like, I'm a person who...
Ever since I died, I've always adopted every animal that I've ever gotten.
Well, minus...
Well, I had a gecko.
I don't think you can really adopt a gecko.
But, you know, I was just... I was a kid, so...
But, you know, I'm also really big, you know, about dog breeding and stuff like that.
Because dog breeding is kind of...
It can be quite questionable sometimes.
And teacup dogs are just not bred for health.
They're bred for aesthetics, which is just such a sad way to go.
Like, sad way to live.
And so, you know, teacup puppies don't have...
They have so many...
So many...
So many health issues.
And so it's just really sad.
So...
So, you know, it's so sad about Sweet Pea, but also just...
Oh my goodness.
There's so many...
If you sent a stream live...
Don't know, there's so many backed up.
Well, thank you, CooperFlag.
Thank you, Ronin.
Oh, I just came in.
Thank you, Ducky.
Thank you, Takizo.
In case I don't get to them later.
If we're, like, in the middle of a something-something.
Middle of a scene.
I was gonna say...
I put in some...
I put in some cheat codes.
I actually...
I did it last week, so I don't remember which ones I put in.
So we will see.
I don't remember...
The passwords.
I put in the passwords.
Passwords.
And also...
I...
I was watching...
Oh my gosh.
Do you guys watch Big Saru?
If you love watching...
Thank you!
If you love watching people mess around in Metal Gear...
And just do big crazy things...
Big Saru is such a great...
He's such a great YouTube channel.
His videos are so funny.
Big Saru is a legend.
I love watching his stuff.
Oh my gosh.
I was watching his Metal Gear Solid 4...
Videos.
And I was like...
Oh my gosh.
I only need...
I'll be able to have the...
The...
The Sun Gun.
In Act 5.
And then I was like...
Wait, no.
I still have to beat...
I still have to beat Mantis.
Was...
I feel like there was one statue that I had.
But maybe not.
Maybe I didn't grab literally any of them.
Sunlight.
Naomi is absolutely everything you said she was.
Yeah, I know.
Hopefully today I don't crash out as hard.
But I do feel...
I do feel that maybe I have some tears to spare.
Because this act can get a little bit emotional.
I like this one a lot though.
Well, the beginning is kind of...
Whatever.
But I heard also that if you put on the beauty's faces...
Or you put on the different camo faces...
Other stuff will happen.
So we'll have to see...
What happens.
I think...
I really don't remember what codes I put in.
I think there was like stuff for music and...
But let's get into the game.
I've yapped...
I've yapped so much now.
I've yapped so much.
And also...
I think I'm gonna have to...
Farm for DP in act 5 as well.
So...
You know...
It's not ideal for this playthrough.
But you know, if I ever play...
Not if...
But whenever I play the game again...
I'll at least have, you know, the DP.
And I'll have the guns and stuff.
Because I saw how you're supposed to...
I looked up a video of how you're supposed to farm.
What I tried to do last time.
And oh my gosh, you guys.
The...
I think I would've been bored out of my mind.
It's such a...
It's not tedious.
It is a little tedious.
So...
I'm trying...
See if I can explain it to you guys.
The area that I was in...
Before we went to the building...
Wait.
Hold on.
There was... OK.
So there was a building that we went into...
To go underground to go see Naomi.
The area prior to that...
Was...
Was the area where I needed to...
To farm at.
And...
Because the guys kept respawning, respawning, respawning.
And basically what I would do is...
I would kill a guy and leave him on the ground in a certain alleyway.
And then one other guy would...
See him in the little alleyway.
He would run over.
You grab him...
Or you hold him up.
He drops his weapon.
Then you grab him and you kill him.
And that will trigger the next guy to...
The guy to respawn again.
But you have to make sure you hold them up...
Before you do it so that they drop their weapon.
Or else you can't kill them or you won't get the weapon.
It would have been so long.
It's a very slow loop.
Yeah.
So I think I would have been so...
I would have been so bored.
And so...
The other way to farm is just killing a bunch of the little dwarfs.
In Act 5.
And I have something for that.
Oh, I remember!
One of the guns I got.
With the password.
So...
Yeah.
So you're telling me it is Naomi's fault.
Absolutely.
Of course.
100%.
Anyway.
Act 3.
Briefing end.
We watch the briefing.
Time to get into the meat of it.
God.
Already ruining my day.
I have to see her stinking face.
As soon as we load up...
I can't, but...
Just look at the right side of the thumbnail.
I would kill a guy and leave him in an alleyway.
Oh, that explains the ghost in the ending screen.
Okay.
Here we go.
I will never and have never endorsed a Naomi and Otacon ship.
You're among friends here.
Why...
You're making...
Bleh, Naomi!
Act 4 has a secret way of getting 1000 AP instantly?
No way.
Really?
That didn't show up when I looked up how to farm.
Oh my gosh.
Europe.
Wow.
So European.
Europe dies.
Pizza!
Resistance.
Oh, that's right.
We have to fight Raging Raven today.
It says I used to be an anime otaku.
Who is that?
Big Boss' corpse.
The framerate.
I'm the only one who thinks Naomi's character.
But guys, I know I get very heated about Naomi, but...
I wanna only talk about her the entire stream, okay?
She ain't here right now, so...
Let's, you know...
I know everybody's got their thoughts and everybody knows my thoughts as well, so...
I think so.
Oh yeah.
You checked him down.
We patted that guy down real good.
Next.
Oh, they're gonna see!
They're gonna see Columbo.
Those uniforms look so heavy.
Next.
Like, they look a little, like...
Set.
Next.
Oh, sorry.
I don't speak English.
I'm in Europe.
Get your ass in the machine.
No!
Ghost in the machine!
Take him away.
Why is he like this?
Why are you like this?
Why did you even get in line?
So stupid.
No smoking.
I'll take him from here.
We've been looking for this man.
Who could that be?
They're being so secretive about everyone.
Come with me.
I'd recognize those cheeks anywhere.
So true.
No!
No making!
What?
Oh my gosh, wait.
It's the famous GIF.
Thank you for the famous GIF!
It's the GIF!
Everybody who hit 30 today.
The man.
Snake!
Hey Snake!
Over here!
He's so embarrassing.
I love him so much though.
Oh Johnny, they could never make me hate you.
No smoking.
Yeah!
Meryl's so cool.
Snake?
Snake looks like an alien without his bandana on.
I can't recognize him as a person.
He's a perpetual...
His poor forehead.
Meryl, listen to him.
It's a hired hit.
How is he smoking while wearing face camo?
Great question.
It's like people that wear zentai suits.
And they like...
Shove food through the mask.
Probably the same.
Oh Snake.
It's so pathetic!
What's wrong Nano?
You don't want a song?
You don't want a birthday song?
No, Snake.
Thank you, Abe King.
But now you're just too damn senile to face the truth.
Wake up and face reality.
Old Snake.
And stay out of our way.
She didn't have to do that!
She didn't have to be like that!
Oh my gosh, I just saw the orange, orange sign.
Cute.
It hurts.
Everybody just bullies Snake in this game.
It's so painful.
I've been watching the show Severance.
And the last episode was like so crazy.
And I just want to be like, Meryl was never cruel!
Is it him?
I don't know who you're talking about.
Oh boy, here we go.
Aw man.
Hairy?
Thanks, Nova!
Resistance.
Big Mama.
I like that name coming out of Otacon's mouth.
Open the item window and select the signal interceptor.
The interceptor constantly monitors PMC voice and data transmissions.
When you've got the signal interceptor equipped and you hear the PMC's chatter about the resistance, check your map.
It should display the location.
Oh, and Snake, I think we've found a way to treat Raiden.
I'll sing Happy Birthday after the cutscene.
Yeah, we got in touch with Dr. Madnar.
Naomi and Sunny are on their way now.
They'll be alright on their own.
They're a few clicks north of where you are now.
It's a non-combat zone, so there won't be any checkpoints.
Nice.
There's even a dialysis machine.
It'll take some time, but I think he'll be okay.
Raiden!
Anyway, you need to hurry and make contact with Big Mama.
I got it.
Why did he do that hand thing with his hand?
With the Big Mama!
Go!
Go find the Big Mama!
X-Ray!
Happy Birthday!
Thank you for the superchats, you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Hold on, I have an itch.
Okay, let's go.
Searching.
I went somewhere.
Snatcher!
Yes.
I want to play Snatcher so badly.
Oh, this guy is looking suspicious.
Mighty, mighty suspicious here.
Hello, civilians.
Okay, wait.
I do...
Oh, he's doing his little whistling.
Okay, I do want to just...
Let's be...
See, I can be Campbell.
Maybe we shouldn't be any of the people though.
But, you know, maybe we should be a hot lady.
Let's be...
Okay, we won't be any of the ones that you guys haven't seen yet, so...
This is so disturbing.
Let's...
Oh yeah, I got this too!
Actually, this kind of fits for...
Does this not fit for Europe?
Does this not work?
Hmm...
That guy.
Oh, Dr. Madnar.
Not suspicious at all.
Maybe we should be hot... Oh, nope.
I mean, we are still hot.
Anybody is hot in a suit.
Chest.
Hot dog, indeed.
We're just a hot lady in a suit.
We're a hot lady in a suit.
It's 1225 in California.
I'm sending this donation.
What, so 20 minutes later?
Uh-oh.
Sorry, they're kind of behind.
They should have added a liquid ocelot, Campbell.
That would be breaking the game.
The sign is very human.
Ronin, thank you.
Oh my goodness.
We just have to hide ourselves from this guy.
But we also have to like...
trail him.
And we have to make sure he also doesn't get into any trouble.
Don't look back.
Delta hype!
I know!
Delta hype real.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited.
Thank you, laptop.
What is
that horrible sound?
Oh, you dropped something.
There is so much noise.
Launching this year.
I will be playing...
Day 1?
I'll probably endurance it.
Honestly.
I'm so excited.
Wait, is this where I have to start protecting him?
Or... I can't remember.
Is this where I have to start knocking the guys out?
He's asleep.
Keep walking.
Why are you whistling so loudly if you don't want people to notice you?
That's all I have to say.
That's all I wonder, you know?
Good night.
Oh, he sees me.
No, he doesn't.
Stop whistling if you don't want anybody to notice you.
Most suspicious person in all of Europe.
What if I went a different way?
I'm so curious.
What if I go up here?
What do you mean report of intruder?
I'm not an intruder.
I'm just...
Oh my god!
Scared the hell out of me.
Don't see me?
Oh my gosh!
Hello sir, going the most roundabout way ever.
I got you.
I got your help.
I'm helping you.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh my god!
He's shivering.
Must be cold.
Why is everybody peeing in this game?
Oh my god, the park stinks.
Which way is he going?
That works.
They're asleep.
You can go.
I'm so curious.
What do they do if they see me?
I don't want to start over though.
I'm too afraid to start over.
Oh my god, where are you going?
Just walk on by.
I won't need to restart.
Are they going to fall in love with me?
Can I have your stuff?
You got any?
Where did he go?
Oh there he is.
My map?
Where is the solid item?
Where is it?
I think we got our guy.
Where is the love dart?
True!
Oh I lost him.
Sir?
Oh there he is.
I wish I could knock him out.
The camera is not so hot right now.
Who's around here?
There he goes.
Thank you!
Ok Otacon, I get it.
I think...
I'm gonna...
I think I don't need to listen anymore.
Don't see me!
That's you!
My resistance!
Oh come on snake, chill out.
Act hot.
I wanna see some guys.
Don't see me.
I'm up his stick.
I'm behind the pole.
Wait, did he see me?
Don't run.
We're chill.
Oh my god, I just heard somebody.
Where are you going?
Oh my god.
Here we go!
We gotta follow.
I was gonna check out the other area.
I probably should have done it.
Oopsie!
Oh well.
Alright.
Wow, you're up.
Wow.
Bird.
Where did he go?
Hello?
Resistance?
Where?
What is this?
Sorry.
Oh my god.
Sir, you need to wear a bell or something.
Good lord.
Thank you so much for the pink.
That's actually my true reaction when I have to go outside and I see another person.
Look at that!
Year of the snake!
Smooth operator.
Yeah!
Snake!
Oh boy!
Oh golly!
Ok, I'm gonna go up to these guys and see what happens.
Do you think they're gonna like me?
Ok Otacon, thank you.
Last year?
Year of the snake?
No, it's this year.
I'm under...
Boss, get down.
That's an enemy gunship.
Hello?
I don't think they cared about my disguise.
No girls allowed!
No!
What?
But I'm hot!
Evasion was so easy.
No way.
No way that actually... I just got away with it.
Hot people privilege?
No, no.
I'm trying!
Oh, wait.
Not auto-aim.
Oh my gosh!
He's gone!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I need to change my ammo.
I have nothing left.
Ok, we need to buy more ammo.
He got caught!
Hot people privilege, real.
Couldn't beat me!
Maybe we get an emotional map.
Wow!
The Beauty and the Beast magazine!
It's the hottest stories.
I mean, these are also the hottest stories.
I'm just gonna get the regular...
Let's save money, you know.
Wait, I'm playing on Sunday.
Does that mean things are on sale?
It didn't give me a message.
I wonder if because I unplugged my PS2 if the clock is out of whack.
I think.
Ah man, isn't the sale on Wednesday?
It's Wednesday and Sunday actually.
Why?
Let's just buy.
Oh yeah, check the big purchases.
The things that we're trying to get.
So true.
Oh no, it is on sale!
Look at that!
Because it's usually 5 million, but now it's 4 million.
Yeah, so it is on sale.
I think I do that impression a little too well.
Did
I see somebody else?
No.
Take out this guy.
There we go.
Take him out.
Caution goes down.
Return to Minky.
Hold it.
Oh, he's all the way over there?
How did he get over there?
Can I get your stuff?
Thank you.
I'm working on it.
Oh, I'm full.
Maybe he shouldn't be part of the resistance if he doesn't know how to take care of himself.
I'm just saying.
You're free.
You're free to go.
He's so...
Maybe...
Oh my gosh.
I didn't notice that guy.
We're fine.
Everything is cool.
We're chill.
Cucumber style.
I'm even going to take out that guy.
I don't know which way...
What are you doing?
He's running around like a chicken with his head cut off.
Are you going this way?
Are you going that way?
Which way are we going?
Huh, buddy?
Bro can't believe his luck.
If I were him, I would think I stink.
I would be quite concerned actually.
I would be like, do I smell bad or...
Why is everybody around me fainting?
I would be nervous.
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Wait, we lost the target.
We lost the target.
Where did he go?
Stinky!
Where are you?
Stinky...
Where is he?
I don't think my disguise worked either guys.
I think I might want to actually change into another normal outfit.
Camouflage.
God, she's...
She's an absolute unit.
Oh my gosh, that's one thing that I noticed about Delta.
If you haven't seen it yet...
They...
Oh wow, look how cute!
Wow, they turned Snake into like...
He is humongous.
Your gun was out.
Oh, do you think that's why they attacked me?
We can try again.
Oh wait, I changed to my suit.
He is just like...
Really...
He looks like a brick wall.
He is like really huge.
Oh my gosh, rats.
Is that you?
Is that him?
What are you waiting on?
What do you see?
I don't see anything.
What are you waiting for?
He's gone.
He's like a ghost.
Scary.
He left.
He left a snack.
Nevermind.
Is he going this way?
Hello?
Floor noodles.
This must be a European specialty.
Hello?
Did he go this way?
I guess we'll check.
Masashi cam, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Do we go the right way?
Where is the suit?
I don't see him.
Oh shoot.
Oh wait, let's go check.
Let's check.
Hello?
I don't think they like my outfit guys.
I don't think they like my outfit.
What do you have against women in suits?
We're still in trouble.
They would hate Helltaker.
Get your ass!
I'm so dead.
Wait!
Shoot!
I got him.
Oh my gosh!
They keep coming.
I'm just going to keep taking your money.
Where are you?
Where are you going?
Oh my gosh!
I see a guy over there!
Oh here he comes.
Oh shoot.
I got him.
Oh man, another one?
I'm not telling him to get up.
I'm telling him to take his stuff.
I got spotted by somebody.
The alert went back up.
Wait, who?
Who saw me?
What do you mean?
It's so bright.
Did you see me?
No.
Look at my stupid dummy helicopter.
We're fine.
Everything is good.
My snake?
Ok, let's check.
For real.
I thought that maybe it's a suit.
Maybe I have to be in my disguise.
I don't know.
Whatever.
I tried.
For the mask you need to have no weapons equipped, including the knife.
Try the camo, since otherwise I know your size.
Vaccinating to ignore if annoying.
No, no, no.
I thought I unequipped my weapon.
Did I not?
Oh, my knife was out.
I thought I had unequipped it.
We'll try one more time.
Dang it, I think it auto equipped the knife.
Ok, now we're chill.
We're chill.
No, we're chill.
This time for sure.
It looks weird.
I mean, snake wearing this disguise looks incredibly weird, so...
I wonder...
This looks so in character.
For the location.
They'll never find me.
The best game of prop hunt ever.
Yeah, we're so normal.
Sorry, we'll just wait for 30 seconds.
Is this your first time through 4?
No, but it is only my second time playing it.
Try equipping the signal interceptor.
You should be able to get intel on the resistance from PMC communications.
I'm not a pro at the game.
I just like the story a lot.
Oh no, he's waking him up.
Oh no!
Wait!
Don't do that!
Sorry, I'm trying to get it so you guys can see, but...
The chat is blocking it a little bit.
Do you think I can go out now?
Hello, fellow soldier.
I give up.
What do you mean the knife?
Guys, it's not equipped.
I can show you.
It's not equipped.
See?
I had it like this.
He just has it in his hand!
Ouch!
Stop!
The problem is the mask.
What's wrong with my mask?
They don't like this beauty?
OK, spoilers for Raging Raven.
You guys know they are all hot.
Whatever.
I gotta move too.
I gotta move back.
Life was still out, but I didn't...Oh my gosh!
I think it comes out.
It's not me taking it out though.
I'm gonna die.
I think I might just die here.
And just restart.
It's OK.
I died on purpose there.
Where am I?
I'm actually not sure of where I am.
Oh,
I'm on this side.
OK, I'm where I just died.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK, I'm in the same place.
OK, that's not so bad.
OK, alright.
We have the knife in the hand, but how do I get it out of the hand?
I did not have it.
How do I have it?
Maybe because my hands are in my pocket?
Take the knife out of your weapons list.
OK, let's try that.
That's a good idea actually.
OK, let's just change it to...
Oh wait, I know what I wanna change it to.
I know what I wanna change it to.
I will show you.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
This is so awesome when you use this weapon.
The Patriot!
We have the Patriot.
Oh my gosh, it does something special when you use it.
But also, do you notice something special too?
Do you notice something?
It has infinite ammo!
Yeah baby!
Try walking only.
Oh yeah, because my...OK.
Walk only.
Alright.
I'm a hot lady.
I'm a hot...Oh wait, did you see that though?
The knife is not in my weapons anymore, but I'm still holding it.
OK, let's walk.
Walk, walk, walk.
What do I change it to?
The face?
They've seen the face.
Are they that smart?
OK, we're gonna go to...Campbell.
Warning, there is a baddie on the loose.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
He looks incredible.
Otacon.
Get this man a peacoat!
Oh my gosh, he looks so good.
Ew!
Brush your teeth Raiden.
What the hell is that?
He looks like a mouth breather.
OK, sorry for spoilers.
You know that all the beauties are hot.
Alright, I'm a hot beauty.
He's hot, but also he's Inspector Gadget.
If I fail this again...
I'm gonna...
Where
is our guy?
Where is he?
It worked!
Oh my gosh, we finally got it to work!
Oh my god, we finally...but where is our guy?
Is he all the way back at the front?
Did he leave?
Mister!
I think walking is the key, because when I run...
You can see the knife come out, but if I walk it's hidden.
Oh, the signal interceptor.
Yeah, thank you.
Mister!
Mister, searching, searching.
Searching for...
For a guy.
If you're a man, put your hands up!
What's that behind them?
What is that?
Hello.
Yeah, you had a hard day, huh?
Oh, it's just a barrel.
OK.
Where is he?
I have.
What?
Forget about him?
What do you mean forget about him?
I was attached to him!
Forget about him?
That's so horrible!
How am I supposed to tell who is a resistance member?
Everybody has the same thing on...
Say a stinko.
Oh man.
Say a resistance.
Oh, Europe is huge.
I was so attached to that guy.
Do I still get recognized if I'm in the spotlight?
Guess not.
Pretty privilege!
Privilege!
I don't see on the map.
Otacon, am I blind?
Otacon, I think my map is not working.
Otacon, I'm blind.
I like hearing the people inside the buildings.
It's kind of fun.
I think he's over here.
Oh my god!
I found him.
Oh!
Oh my god!
He's in love with me!
Oh my god, he's checking me out!
See you later.
It's me, your girlfriend.
Sir, don't forget the mission!
Oh my god, he's blinded by love.
Pretty privilege.
Is this what it means to be hot?
People on the street just fall in love with you and...
What?
I can't believe this is happening to me!
He's running.
I'm following.
Does he need me to knock the people out?
I feel like he should, you know...
No, he's gone.
Okay.
I'm going too.
Act like you are new to this.
Guys, I'm dead.
People, like 90% of the population can't even see me.
What are you talking about?
Not a lot of people have a sixth sense, okay?
Acting like I, you know...
What is this?
Maybe he can get behind them.
I can too.
Don't knock that over.
Don't knock that over!
Oh my god, my guys.
Of course, an idiot.
Only an idiot would fall in love with me.
There you go, you're welcome.
Of course, it had to be this dummy-dumb.
You're good.
Wait, where are you running to?
I knew... As soon as I saw that can, I knew it was going to be bad news bears.
Where did he go?
Hello?
Nothing?
What the hell?
Excuse me?
What are you doing?
I'm your girlfriend!
Now, I'm a drum can.
He saw the knife.
I thought
I...
This part is so stupid.
I feel like I should just...
I feel like it would just be easier to do it the way I was before.
Where did he go?
Sir?
You don't hate me anymore, do you?
Oh gosh, these are so tricky to find.
You were in love with me!
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
Knock him out.
That's how I feel too.
Yeah, we should just knock him out.
Alright.
Where are you going?
You know you could have taken the stairs, but instead...
Instead, you take that way.
Yeah, this part is a little, you know... It's a little weak.
But it's not my least favorite.
If I crouch, I can't tell if crouching...
What crouch-walk works too, but...
You know.
We're following him.
It's fine.
We're good.
Had a gun this whole time too.
Son of a bitch.
He could have been doing all his own stunts.
Instead, I'm the one helping him out.
Hello, resistance.
Don't mind me.
I'm just a hot lady trailing you.
You have to hide the knife and the cake.
I don't think we want to hide the cake.
I think this guy wants to see every bit of the cake.
Doesn't he?
You don't think so?
You don't think this guy wants to see every last cake?
Every last frosting?
The jam inside?
Alright.
We're walking still.
What did I just hear?
Oh my God.
What the hell?
You're supposed to be...we're on the same side.
I think I just got mugged.
Oh wait.
He's coming back up.
First time ever in Europe.
This sucks.
Oh, I have full ration.
That's right.
Where did he get the outfit from anyway?
I don't see any guys here.
Where did he get it from?
Press.
That's nice.
I'm going to change my face.
Sorry.
I don't want him to...
Oh wait.
Beauty.
We're this beauty.
Where did he go?
Oh shoot.
I lost him again.
Oh good.
We need more ammo.
I'm being super slow, super careful.
I think that's a bird.
We're going this way.
I think he went this way.
Oh.
Is that our...
It's me!
Just a hot lady.
Just a hot lady trailing a guy.
Yeah, we're staying cool.
We're staying cool.
What are you guys doing?
What are we all doing?
OK.
We're walking.
That's our guy right there, right?
Wow.
He walks his own path.
Is an individual.
Sir?
Do you need me to be right behind you or...
Closer?
He's not whistling.
He's not moving.
Is it the wrong guy?
Oh shoot.
Money!
Wrong guy.
Oh.
No, that is not resistance member.
Is that guy?
Oh no, they are...
OK, this guy is walking with purpose.
I think this is our man.
This is our man.
Maybe.
Oh yes, yes, yes.
I'm walking chill with you.
Wow, those birds are getting really close to your face.
I like how they hit...
At Raven with all the birds around.
I'm gonna eat this ration and I'm gonna grab the other one.
Orb.
OK.
Don't call me snake.
Call me...
Hotness.
Call me Cynthia Hot Lady.
Call me...
Your forever babe.
Hi Cynthia Hot Lady.
Actually, you know what's a hot name?
Sabrina.
That's such a hot name.
Meep meep.
Sorry.
Sabrina from Pokemon.
Exactly, that's who I think of.
Sabrina from... The Teenage Witch?
I prefer Salem.
Like Carpenter?
Yes, Sabrina Carpenter.
But no, I think of Sabrina from Pokemon.
And that's my definitive...
Oh yeah, that's why she's so hot.
Gosh, can you walk any slower?
Please, sir.
Would you still hate us if we were a worm?
Probably even more so.
No, I save worms.
Do you guys not save worms?
Worms.
Like if a worm is...
You know, you see a worm...
On the side of the sidewalk, you don't save them?
Oh my gosh, the slowest ever walker.
Ever to exist.
Bye bye.
Oh, okay, never mind.
Oh, he's back to normal.
Why did you change out of your disguise?
He heard me.
Are you self-conscious?
I'd be like, nobody would ever hire you with the pace you go at.
Oh wait!
Uh-oh.
No, I wouldn't
even move!
Oh no.
Guys, I'm sorry.
The cutscene...
I
didn't even move an inch.
You guys saw that.
I was just standing there and the cutscene happened.
Oh no.
Maybe we get one more shot.
Oh!
Wait, nope, never mind.
We're a lady.
I'm sorry everybody.
Just ignore the woman.
I think he...
Doesn't he... He changes though.
From what I remember.
I'm pretty sure he gets out of the outfit.
I can't ignore a woman.
Yes you can!
Yes!
See, see, see!
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
We're okay.
Oh yeah.
Show me, lady.
Hey,
what are you talking about?
Angel.
The posters!
Should have been me!
Wow, an apple.
Lucky guy indeed.
Should have been me!
Very impressive CQC, Snake.
Are you my mama?
Are you...
The Big Mama?
Call me Mama.
Big Mama.
Here's your gun.
Okay, lore dump time.
Children are terrible.
You can't grow a human being in a test tube.
Not even a clone.
You need a woman's body to give it life.
You mean...
A surrogate mother.
That's an awfully cold way to put it.
I am your mother.
I gave birth...
For the Patriots.
She can say the Patriots.
Yummy.
Mama.
Big in Huawei.
She's big in Japan.
Liquid.
Yeah.
Zero.
During the Cold War when the United States and the Soviet Union were still at odds.
It was in that chaotic era that the Patriots were born.
Forgot all about Zero.
What do you mean?
I was one of the founding members.
You.
Zero created the Patriots to manage and control the American state.
That control endured long after the Cold War ended.
The organization became an empty shell.
Continuing to function through A.I.s.
Those A.I.s are responsible for the creation of the war economy.
And they gave rise to the sons of the Patriot system.
But I am partly to blame.
I bear some of the guilt for creating the organization.
It was right after I first met your father.
Big Boss.
Back in 1964 I was ordered to take part in a CIA op called Operation Snake Eater.
Which concerned a new weapon the Soviets were developing at the time.
My mission was to support a certain agent.
That agent later became Big Boss.
I knew him as Snake.
Snake?
Yes.
Naked Snake.
That was his code name at the time.
A name he would give to you.
I didn't get the naked part.
The commander of this mission was a man called Zero.
The head of Special Forces Unit Fox.
Back then I was working as a double agent for the Chinese.
My objective was to secure the location of the philosopher's legacy.
A massive cache of hidden wealth.
And report it to Beijing.
I was to acquire a microfilm showing the location of secret funds.
Funds amassed by the allied powers during World War 2.
It's all about that money baby.
And was expelled from China.
I took the apple from the snake and was cast out of Eden.
After years on the run I ended up in Hanoi.
That's where I met him again.
It was around then that Zero used the massive funds contained in the philosopher's legacy...
to start a new organization.
The Patriots.
Which would carry out the final wishes of a certain legendary hero.
The initial membership consisted of Big Boss, Sigint, Paramedic and their commander Zero.
Oh and there was one more...
Oh just you know one guy.
Oh boy I wonder who.
Who is now Liquid.
After your father rescued me in Hanoi I went to America and joined their organization.
Zero's goal was to achieve a unity of thought and awareness.
He believed that was what the Boss wanted.
And the rest of the Patriots followed his lead.
The Boss?
The Boss was a legendary hero from the Second World War.
Known as the Mother of Special Forces.
She had an almost overwhelming charisma about her.
The CIA feared this, so they had her eliminated.
If she had survived, the world of the 21st century might have been a very different place.
We were all influenced by the Boss's will.
It was what drove us to create this organization, to be closer to that spirit.
Zero decided that in order to lead the people, we needed a special kind of icon.
So he turned to Big Boss, the last son of the Boss.
He shared more of her life than anyone else.
It was Big Boss, the true heir to her legacy, who was best suited to play this role.
Zero elevated Big Boss, the hero who saved the world, to the status of an idol.
The truth behind Big Boss became riddled with exaggeration, misrepresentation and outright lies.
Zero disseminated these stories among the masses, and gathered the rich and powerful to his banner.
Every era needs its symbols to control the people.
Whether it be the stars and stripes...
Or the snakes.
Or the hammer and sickle.
Close enough.
The idol.
He's my idol, my oshi.
As the times and currents of politics changed, so too did Zero.
Eventually, he became a prisoner of his own lust for power.
Sparking friction between him and Big Boss, who resented playing the puppet.
With Big Boss drifting away, Zero realized he would need insurance.
Something that would perpetuate the existence of Big Boss, their organization's icon.
And so Zero secretly embarked on a new project.
Its goal was to create a clone of Big Boss, the ultimate soldier.
The project was led by Dr. Clark, known at the time as Paramedic.
After dozens of failures, they finally, miraculously, succeeded in producing a fertilized egg.
The egg used in this successful in vitro fertilization came from Dr. Clark's assistant.
Blood from the East flowed within your veins.
Give birth to Big Boss.
Don't forget he is half Japanese!
I asked to serve as the surrogate mother.
He's half Japanese everybody!
I loved him.
Everyone...
Nine months later, I gave birth to two Big Bosses.
You and Liquid.
Babies.
It didn't matter that you were clones or that they had manipulated your DNA.
You were born the same way as any other normal child.
From your mother's womb.
I like how the lady...
proved to be the final straw for Zero and Big Boss.
Determined to oppose Zero and his plans, Big Boss broke away from the Big Boss.
He left the business, created his own mercenary company, and drifted around the world.
I'm sorry.
Your father never wanted you.
Human life isn't meant to be manipulated like that.
I knew that, but I wanted you.
You just wanted the Boss' babies.
It's crazy.
What Zero wanted was an orderly world, one governed by rules.
His fortune grew through countless wars, and his words influenced decision-making all the way up to the Oval Office.
As the world saw the rise of digital technology, IT, the internet, and genetics, the Patriots' power grew...
He's absorbing all this information.
Their roots spread and took hold throughout the globe.
In time, it began to dictate the fate of entire nations from the shadows.
And before we knew it, the Patriots, the proud police of the world, started bringing an entire planet under their control.
Save the game.
Loud.
I'm just gonna keep doing new saves.
You guys, oh my gosh, before I continue...
Nevermind.
Nevermind, I don't have a choice.
I was gonna explain something I tried to do, but next time I save I'll...
I'll explain it.
But their execution was flawed.
Zero developed weapons, amassed armies, used information for extortion, all in order to gain more wealth.
He was obsessed with controlling awareness on the inside from the outside.
But...
I cannot imagine that's what the boss would have wanted.
They both misinterpreted her will.
They're all silly.
So began the war between Zero and Big Boss.
Oh yeah.
Opposing interpretations, each striving to realize the boss's will.
And strange love, you know.
Everything you see today stems from their cold war.
Just two guys with mummy issues.
Putting the whole world in chaos.
Damn,
Eva's got abs.
Mammy.
There was nothing left of the boss's noble will in their struggle.
All that remained was hatred.
A passion to destroy one another.
Big Boss returned to the U.S.
with a plan in mind, and once again assumed command of Foxhound.
Foxhound?
In Outer Heaven, and then Zanzibar Land...
Zanzibar Land!
Big Boss plotted coup d'etat against Zero.
But you, Solid Snake, his own clone, foiled his plan four times.
Big Boss and Gray Fox, Frank Jaeger, left near death.
Zero recovered their bodies.
Frank Jaeger's entire body was reconstructed through surgery.
And he was reborn as the Cyborg Ninja.
I should have just left him for dead.
Big Boss, now a vegetable, became a prisoner of Zero even in death.
For Zero, more than anyone else, your father was an irreplaceable icon.
No, the truth is, for Zero, he was an irreplaceable friend.
After Big Boss' betrayal, Zero could no longer believe in something so uncertain as life.
He lost his belief in everything.
Nations, organizations, individuals.
Zero was no longer willing to place his organization in the hands of the next generation.
Instead, he set up a network of AIs, a decision-making system formed from all the information he had accumulated.
He built four AIs, GW...
But your AIs are gonna be wrong if you already had the wrong interpretation.
Stupid ass.
If the information you're feeding them is the information you know.
Did they make AI art though?
Yeah, make them... I guess that's the only way you can make them worse.
Big Boss isn't allowed to live or die.
He's trapped for eternity in a brain-dead prison.
To bind himself to his friend, to ensure his rule over the world, Zero transformed Big Boss into an icon.
Neither living nor dead.
Sounds almost like a religion.
Naturally, Ocelot and I planned to free him from Zero's prison.
We enlisted Naomi Hunter, an authority in the field of nanomachine research, into our organization.
And we used Frank Yeager to kill Dr. Clark.
Ocelot tortured the DARPA chief Donald Anderson, also known as Sigint, to death.
I love how they just throw that in.
With Paramedic and Sigint dead, Zero was the only one left.
But we too paid a price.
I lost Ocelot.
But you know it's him if you read the ending game timeline.
And certainly not for Zero.
He was fighting for Big Boss.
He idolized him.
Spoilers where?
What are you talking about?
Huh?
I didn't say spoilers.
Raiden.
Raiden's... everyone's always sticking their nose where they don't belong.
Prosper, welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
I'm so glad they took off the beauty face.
So glad.
To eat him.
Zero wanted to create a messiah.
A legend.
That would never die.
I mean, but nobody wants Soup as a hero.
Oh my hero, he's Soup.
He's literally like mush in there.
Soup Snake.
The real Liquid Snake is in there.
Oh my god.
I feel so bad for Eva too.
Imagine seeing the person you loved as Soup.
In like a...
Like whatever this is.
This... oh my god, it's so gross.
This is so messed up.
Manipulating people's minds for the sake of his own ego.
It's so... it's... oh my god.
Wonder how he tastes.
There's a lot of salt in there probably.
Metal Gear Solid 3 Soup Eater.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Oh wow.
Oh no.
I sure hope there's not three guys in a trench coat.
Ah...
Oh wow, look at that swagger.
Oh, there really is three guys in a trench coat.
Move!
Yeah, take care of them Big Mama!
Oh, it should have been me.
Oh my god.
Eva!
Autobots?
What do you want?
OK OK Yes ma'am
Yeah!
Triumph!
Oh, she's a beaut.
Oh, she's so shiny.
So well taken care of.
Ugh, those dang video games.
lol It's me right now.
Those dang video games.
I like how she says children, but these look like grown ass men.
These are... these are... these are real men.
Children where?
lol Oh yeah.
Children to her.
Marvel Rivals is a plot by Marvel.
Yeah!
Popeye and Snake.
Oh my gosh, just like old times.
Mom!
I'm not gonna be weird.
It's my actual mom.
Well, it's Snake's actual mom.
lol Maybe she's gonna be weird though.
A while?
No!
Big Mama!
Before we do this part though, I really have to pee.
So we'll just watch all of this and then as soon as it starts I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
I gotta go!
I'm so fast!
I'm like the fast 10 minutes.
Please!
Or I'm going to!
Oh please!
Please.
Oh my god.
My ectoplasm.
Okay.
Okay, I'm back.
I... I open my door and Pies comes running at me.
She's like... because she likes to hide in my room.
And then I go to the bathroom and I hear... I hear Butaro sneeze.
My cats are so cute.
Welcome back!
I'm back!
Do you wash your hands?
I always wash my hands.
I do.
Alright.
Let's go baby!
No matter what!
Okay!
Oh god.
Oh,
that's a good guy.
I
wonder if I have this.
What am I using right now?
Let's use... I wanna try... Okay.
I don't... Okay.
Yeah, we wanted the Patriot.
Oh yeah, turn on auto-aim.
You're so right.
It's good to use here.
Okay, you guys are not ready for what the Patriot does.
It's so good if you've never seen it.
Oh, it's so good.
Okay, ready?
Oh, I don't have it equipped.
Equip!
I can't see anything!
I'm trying!
I'm shooting.
Yeah, get his ass!
Get his ass!
Oh my god!
It's so good.
Get them Snake!
Get them!
There is no one else.
I got them all.
So much for a peaceful run, right?
Oh, those are our friends.
Just kidding.
That's the
right...
rubber bullets?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, the froggies.
Our froggies!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I can't see anything!
I'm just auto locked on!
I'm just shooting!
I'm just going!
I just shoot to kill!
It doesn't matter what!
I did that last week.
Just get me talking about Naomi.
I'll show you my rage.
I definitely don't think they wanted Big Boss blown up!
Greetings Europe!
Hello Europe!
It's a lot more chaotic here than I thought it would be.
Where do you get the figure in this stage?
We do have to fight Raging Raven.
We'll get it there.
Oh no.
No!
Yeah baby!
OK Kiba.
I'm not auto aiming.
That means it's not me.
It's a game issue.
I
got you!
Oh my god, she loves me!
She loves me!
My mom is giving me praise!
I wonder what my death count is going to be like here.
What's my death count going to be here?
I'm scared.
I got you.
I already got him.
He didn't even need to tell me.
He's dead.
I even auto caught.
Everybody is so happy for me.
Who's driving this thing?
Hello?
I got him.
Probably.
I love the Patriot.
Here they come!
Let's go.
I got her.
Guys,
this is great gameplay.
I'm alright.
I'm just holding down and shooting.
Yeah, but the cinematics are crazy.
Right on!
Oh my god, Shaggycon.
We'll
get revenge for you, mama!
Oh my goodness, I can't see anything.
It's all just chaos craziness here.
Oh my god!
I can't see anything!
What the hell is happening?
The world's greatest chase scene ever!
I'm still fighting!
Did we?
They were right behind us.
I don't think we did.
What a thrill.
My god!
There it is.
The van.
OK Eyes on the road, buddy.
Eyes on the road.
They are right behind us again.
No!
The soup.
Eva, I need you.
Is that you?
A mother's work is never done.
Help me, mama!
Not again.
No one got involved.
I know, right?
If I were a pedestrian, I would not be going outside.
Hell no.
Use the cure menu.
Oh my god.
His booty.
It's sore.
The children!
Maybe also call medical help.
Please.
Oh gosh, I don't remember how to fight Raging Raven.
I don't remember how...
Oh shoot.
Alright, well.
Also, where the heck will her statue be?
OK.
Oh gosh.
The Mosin.
Yeah, I think that's what we'll have to use.
That's what I was thinking too.
I wish I could just go blasting with my Patriot.
Oh gosh.
Ah, I forgot that it was this soon.
I thought it was... Actually, I couldn't remember what it was.
I was completely wrong with what I remembered.
Oh no, Snake, the syringe!
Oh my gosh, Naomi, now is not the time!
Why do you have to make such a flawed product and then give it to the masses?
The IVS.
We get it, you're a bird.
Oh my god.
Ah!
I love the overlapping voices.
They're so cool!
The overlapping voices is so awesome.
They
sound so awesome.
OK, alright, OK, alright, OK, alright.
Oh gosh, I don't remember how to do this fight, but I'll do my best.
OK, we have the Mosin actually in.
I am gonna switch from this just to have our...
Is there anything else that I can use that...
Like, does this have rubber bullets?
Can I get...
No!
The shotty.
Is the shotgun the only other thing?
But the shotgun is only good if she comes close and she's kind of a far away fight.
V-Ring or Mosin?
Wish I could use my real gun.
OMG, it's the wings from Fortnite.
You know what, let's just have it equipped just in case because, you know, anything that doesn't do...
Damage damage, I think is good.
Hold on, I wanna see something real quick.
I think we can only use this against...
The last one.
OK, um...
I don't know if... Oh wait.
I have smoke grenades but they're ID locked, that's so messed up.
OK, um...
I can't help me.
Oh, I didn't even know there were searchlights.
Thank you.
Oh, it says the same thing.
OK...
They spotted me right away.
OK, um, shoot.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, how do I... Oh, like that.
Did
I get her?
No, I didn't even.
This sucks.
Can you, like, come over here?
Why didn't it shoot?
Was I too close to the wall?
Ah!
Oh my god.
I don't remember this fight at all.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm so sorry.
It'll take me a second to get used to it.
I'll get it.
What's coming?
OK, what's coming?
What does that mean?
Who?
Me?
What?
Snake.
Oh my god, I can't see anything.
Oh, hello.
Oh my god.
Get up, snake.
Oh, shoot.
I'm just standing out in the open.
With this thing.
Maybe I should have switched to the shotgun there.
I should have switched to the shotgun.
It's OK, I'm panicking a little bit.
OK.
She's so fast.
OK,
where is my... Alright.
Get up, snake!
You are overheating.
Oh no.
Oh no, no, no!
Who's... You're telling me...
Maybe here.
Which one is she?
Oh shoot.
I don't know.
Oh shoot!
I don't know!
Oh wait, is that her?
Wait.
There she is again.
Wait, yeah.
I wonder if I can get her again.
Oh, is that her?
I think so.
Oh shoot!
I didn't realize I had no bullets in.
Oh my god.
No!
I think I just saw her!
Are you gonna come in here?
Or...
I
think she's gonna be too fast.
Oh my goodness lady.
Ah, shoot!
Come on!
Oh my god.
I tried... What happened to my gun?
Snake!
What happened to it?
Oh my god.
Auto-aim please.
Auto-aim!
Maybe I don't want it on after all.
Ah!
Holy moly, what is she doing?
I can't read her movements at all you guys.
This fight is so tricky for me.
This fight is so hard for me.
I can't read anything.
Everything feels like it's all over the place.
Like for real.
Please!
I can't read anything.
She's so fast.
She is!
I'm going back down here.
I feel like I can have more place to roam around here.
I just don't know.
Oh, it's quiet.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm going back downstairs to get the other ration that was down here.
The thermal health?
I'm not sure actually.
I don't know.
This is a question.
I'm gonna try it.
What's select mode?
Oh.
I'm binoculars.
I'm...
It said what's select mode.
Oh, Sunny!
Silly me!
Oh, I don't think I can see anything in...
Oh gosh!
No.
Normal.
Twin barrel.
Yeah!
We got her.
Nice.
Nice suit.
What?
What do you mean I'm not here?
Okay.
Sorry.
I'm getting a little panicky.
It's hard for me to...
It's hard for me to control movement sometimes.
I get panicky, especially in this fight.
I don't know what to do at all.
Oh shoot.
I'm gonna go back upstairs.
Oh
my gosh!
That was so close.
Oh!
Oh my god!
I wish I could reload how I used to in the old days.
Oh no.
No.
I'm out of ammo.
Am I?
What is a...
What does it use?
It uses... Oh, the V-Ring.
That's right.
V-Ring.
V-Ring ammo.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay.
Should be okay.
I really can't see anything.
Holy cow.
She got me good.
She got me.
Holy cow.
Oh, that was close.
Oh, we're back to...
Oh, she's here again.
That's right.
I don't need laser eye surgery anymore.
I'm happy for you.
There she is.
I wish I could... I wonder...
Where did she
go?
I think that's her right there.
Does
that hurt?
No.
That's her!
Stop not moving.
Oh, there she is.
No!
My shot!
Come on, snake!
Snake, get out of fire.
Stop being on fire.
That's mean.
We're so close.
How did I not get caught?
Maybe I did get caught.
There she is.
We're so close.
Good stuff.
Now, if I could just see where she's at.
She could actually just come back in here.
She could just come back in here and we could have a little bit of a shoddy time again.
No!
Are you kidding me?
I feel like I don't need the solid eye very much.
Actually...
I'm stuck!
Please.
Damn it.
So unlucky.
We're so close.
I wish I could tell where it's going to explode from.
Okay.
It's quiet.
This is the strongest...
Get up, snake!
Get up!
Snake!
I really needed to not do that.
Oh my gosh.
I'm overheating.
There she goes.
Okay.
And she'll do her little calm down thing, right?
Where is she?
Oh no.
Oopsie.
I wonder if we can try and get her again.
So close!
Nice shot, Minky.
Thank you!
She's so close.
Yes I am.
Okay.
I just missed her.
Barely.
I wonder if I can get her.
Which one is her though?
That's the issue.
Which one is her?
Is the harder...
Damn it!
She's raging again.
Oh my gosh.
The amount of salt this woman has.
Puts me to sh...
I really need to watch a speedrun of this fight in particular.
Just one more!
Just one more hit!
Where did she go?
Damn it.
Okay guys, where is the statue?
Where is the statue?
It's upstairs.
Go all the way up.
Okay!
I'll go all the way up.
Go to the top of the building.
Okay!
I'll go to the top of the building.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
All the way up in a corner.
Okay!
Should be able to...at the top of the building, so get ready to run.
Okay.
Sorry that one took so long.
Hopefully we don't have to do it again.
Hopefully I can find the statue.
Hopefully I can find it easy.
Raging.
I think it's this actress?
She's like an animal activist now.
I periodically see her on Twitter.
She hates the eagles.
That's the other team during the Superbowl.
The birds are picking up my flesh and my soul!
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I love body suits.
We're on the second floor, right?
She's so smooth.
She's like a ballerina.
Did you learn that from Vamp?
Why has he got his hand up there?
Does she smell bad?
She probably just smells like gasoline.
Alright.
Alright, run snake.
Snake time to run the...
Oh no!
Don't threaten me with a good time!
Oh, they put us all the way down at the bottom.
That sucks.
In a corner.
In a corner!
Easy.
Okay.
Raging raven doll.
That scared me.
Wait a second.
They switch out the weapon.
It's kind of annoying.
It was definitely not... It was my pistol before.
Photo shoot?
I'll try.
Did she come up here?
Where is she?
Jesus Christ!
Oh my God!
She's fast!
Stop!
Sayonara!
Oh shoot.
Got her.
I'm so bad at this.
What the hell?
That hit.
That definitely hit.
Once it gets closer to time, I'll use the shotty.
I
thought she would...
I just want to get close-ish though, because I don't want to...
I'm so bad at this.
Sorry guys.
She was right there.
How could you miss?
She was right in front of you.
Oh my God!
He did it again!
I'm just wasting bullets at this point.
When does the timer start?
Aim for Booba.
It worked!
Look at you, Micmac!
It only works once.
Takes a few minutes.
OK, we'll just keep running around.
I don't want to get her too low.
She leaned.
Here it is!
Music!
Songs!
I forgot about the moans.
I don't remember...
Do you guys hear it?
Very sus background.
I did not remember the moans.
I guess we'll turn on our music now.
Are you going to start dancing again?
Wait, hold on.
I don't think I have the...
Guys, I don't have a camera.
It's on the plane.
I thought I got it though.
When does it...
Does Dreben sell it?
Let's check.
I don't think so.
That's how you're playing the game with one hand.
What do you mean?
Two hands always on the steering wheel.
The camera is on the plane.
I thought I searched the plane though.
Have I just not gotten it?
We'll get it next time then.
Sorry guys.
Oh wait, what am I doing?
Stop!
Start dancing!
Urgh!
Stun grenade launcher.
There
she goes!
Another
concert.
Can we get another concert?
I want to do it.
Now you guys have seen the funny dance.
Yay!
I
wonder who would be the second person though.
I already know the dance just from watching it there.
Oh, return to baby.
Little baby.
Alright, that's three statues down.
We just need two more.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Oh.
Everything okay?
I don't know why windows.
Nothing popped up on my monitor.
But I can't see because this is full screen.
Nice.
Oh no.
I know it's coming up.
Guys, while Drebin is giving lore drops, I'm going to go get some water.
Every time Drebin does his lore drops, I got to go get water.
I'll be right back.
You listen to him, okay?
You listen to nice old Drebin, alright?
He's going to tell you all about Raging Raven.
Something bad happened to her.
Some birds picked out her flesh.
I don't know.
I'll be right back.
Now that's a collector's item.
How old was she?
I'd say about twenty.
But she had years of soldiers' rage hidden away in that youthful body of hers.
Soldiers?
Yeah, the soldiers of Ake.
A place that hasn't seen peace in a long, long time.
She was captured by one side or another.
And kept caged up like an animal.
Along with God knows how many other kids.
Anonymous violence.
Exactly.
It's unknown whether her captors were with the government or the rebels.
In any case, they got their kicks by abusing these helpless little kids day after day after day.
That constant barrage, that battlefield rage slowly built up inside their bodies.
Their minds.
The kids tried to keep each other's spirits up.
Always clinging to the hope that someone would come to their rescue.
Barely surviving off of scraps of food.
But those soldiers didn't stop.
They called the kids parasites and shit-eating ravens.
Beat them even harder.
Then one morning, the soldiers just up and left.
Leaving the surviving kids to be eaten alive by the birds.
Almost like one of those sky burials.
Okay, I'm back.
One by one, their bodies were picked apart by ravens' feet.
Oh no!
Oh, he already started!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, welcome back.
Thank you!
I think that was just the cut, the long cutscene after this though, right?
Kinda short.
She ripped the ravens pecking at her to pieces.
And then went after the soldiers.
And when she finally caught up with them, she waited until nightfall like a hunter awaiting its prey.
The upcoming cutscene though is a real treat.
They say that when a raven cries, a man dies.
No more gameplay.
Screeching and cawing, she killed every last living being in the camp.
But I want to get the camera.
Both the soldiers and the civilians they'd enslaved.
In her eyes, there was no longer a difference.
The cruelty her friends had suffered.
The pain and humiliation she'd endured.
Hers was the distillation of the rage that decades of war had imparted on those soldiers.
It was her strength and her greatest weakness.
You're something else, Snake.
You managed to cleanse Raven of her rage.
No, seriously.
It's because my rage is greater.
You're the seed of war.
In fact, I'd say you might even be war itself.
That's so mean, Drebin.
You don't even know us.
You don't even know him.
You still got half the B&B Corps ahead of you.
Keep your eye on the ball, pal.
Such a jerk.
You know what, I don't know if you can just go up to people and be like, yeah, you're literal war.
You know what else you are?
Cancer.
You're just like the worst things in the world.
Let me just keep naming off the terrible things that you could be.
So rude.
Gosh, we're trying to be the good guy here and you're like, yeah, you're war.
Big Booba Corps?
No.
Maybe.
I don't think all of them have a big booba though.
Sorry if that disappoints you.
But there should be a little bit of something for everyone, right?
Yeah.
Oh, Big Mama.
Big Mama, we cleansed her.
Oh, I can't.
I can't.
I managed to get in touch with the children.
The Pix is safe.
We're going to rendezvous on the riverbank downstream.
Land and air routes are cut off.
But there's a cruiser waiting for us.
The Volta River is our only chance of escape.
Let's get out of here.
Hurry.
Good thinking.
The way he's holding her hand.
Such a gentleman.
Eva, we need you.
We can't drive this bike.
We don't know how.
That's ominous.
Triumph.
There's no need to keep lying to myself.
I only get off my bike when I fall in love.
Why did you let her just be there by herself anyway?
To the river.
There should be fewer of them down there.
Why are they so cute though?
What?
I'm gonna getcha!
Cure menu please, thank you.
Okay, I was gonna say this last time I saved the game.
Okay guys, I was gonna be...
I was gonna be a little cheeky, okay?
Let me show you with my old save files.
Spoilers a little bit maybe.
But...
So, one...
Oh gosh, lots of spoilers.
One place to...
To...
To grind is...
Act 5.
And it's right before a certain room.
It's right before a certain room.
That you have to crawl through.
And I was like, oh my gosh, if I just load up my old...
My old save.
I could go and grind the DP there.
And then I could get the stuff, right?
And I think, if I remember correctly, it would transfer over.
If not, I was just gonna play up until the part and skip a bunch of the stuff.
But anyway...
Um...
And...
But...
I...
Didn't save.
I would've had to go and fight the last boss again.
Like the, um...
I would've had to fight, uh...
What's it called?
Not Psycho Mantis.
Again.
And that would've been...
I didn't...
I really didn't want to.
And it's all like having to go through the boat and everything.
And so I was just like...
So it was like...
It was like...
I said not Psycho Mantis.
I can't remember what they call her.
Something Mantis.
The Beauty Mantis.
What's her name?
Screaming Mantis.
Thank you.
Spoiler Mantis.
No.
Screaming Mantis.
We've already seen her, you guys.
It's not a spoiler.
We know we have to fight her.
But, um...
Yeah, so I was like...
Dang.
I would've had to fight her again.
I could've skipped all the cutscenes.
Just to farm.
But...
I think I'm too far gone now.
I'm too far gone in the game.
Too far and everything.
So...
Some of chat hasn't seen her face yet.
Yeah?
I'm not showing you her face.
This is...
No?
What you're assuming is incorrect.
Yeah.
But anyway.
So...
Who's that cutie?
Actually, they also already have mentioned her before.
So it's not a spoiler.
But...
I won't say.
It is...
You know, they've already talked about her in the game.
So...
But it's okay.
Oh, Big Mama.
Please, Snake.
Please, assist her or something.
Please.
Oh.
My.
Freak.
Who's my favorite freak over there?
Not just any liquid.
Liquid...
Snake,
put on your glasses.
Can't you read the room, Snake?
Can't you tell by her reaction?
Is that it?
Oh.
Old man.
Don't listen to him!
Snake.
Come on.
Oh my gosh, Quinn.
Thank you so much.
I can't sing happy birthday right now.
But please remind me later.
No.
Ow.
Why
are the old men so nimble?
Don't pull it out.
Oh my god.
The military part.
I don't even have a body and I can sell this part.
Remember GW?
The AI they think they lost?
It's mine.
Part of my army.
Impossible.
We destroyed it.
Your worm only managed to cut GW into little pieces.
Pieces we were able to reconstruct.
Maybe.
Then we stowed it away inside JD's network.
This man's body has served me well, allowing me to pass every security barrier between me and GW.
After all, the Patriot system is nothing more than a machine.
While the GW is a spook inside the network, there's no way JD would recognize it as an external threat.
Once I destroy JD with a nuclear strike, the Patriot's network will be mine.
And then I'll build my haven, free from all forms of control.
I'll cast aside my old identity and take my own name for the first time.
You could do that now.
Nothing is stopping you.
Liquid, you're planning to recreate the Patriots?
Snake, we were created by the Patriots.
We're not men.
We're shadows in the shape of men.
We're freaks who never should have existed.
We're a system, an insurance that future generations never prosper.
The Patriots saw fit to create us, and in doing so became our only raison d'etre.
Snake!
I think we're all in agreement for the first part.
We will be reborn.
If I just... If I just... If I just... If I just...
My OTP!
Why did you get that apple?
Bad apple.
Recognize it.
Recognize it!
He hates Spru.
So long as we both live, the world will not know an age of light.
If we're to pass the baton to the next generation, the only choice left to us is death.
Boss.
Good.
The players have all assembled.
The time has come for you to witness.
Witness our moment of triumph.
Go!
Stop acting like you're concerned.
I hate you.
Drown in the ocean!
She's like, I'm sorry you're hurting.
I know I caused it.
Bright.
That's what my cats look like when I turn on the kitchen light and they're begging.
You got this.
I go bright every time I turn on the light.
Someone push her over.
Drop your weapons and stand down.
Yeah, shoot Meryl, please.
I know, shoot first Meryl.
Don't even...just shoot him.
Don't even tell him to stand down.
Just shoot.
Raging Raven with her combined hate for Neo.
True.
Just shoot him!
You have all the man power!
Do it!
Right now!
Look how cool he is though.
I love...I love Ocelot.
I love Liquid.
I love Liquid Ocelot.
Now shoot!
Shoot!
This is what the taxpayer's money goes to, right?
You got all that ammo!
Do something with it!
My taxes paid for this!
I know we're still in Europe, but they have USA boats!
This cutscene is so long.
Why didn't they shoot?
I gotta get a real good look at them.
Oh my god, Vamp is so dramatic.
You're not an actual vampire, you dingus.
We've literally seen you go out in sunlight.
Stop being so dramatic.
Discord light mode.
Well, actually, Discord light mode, yeah.
I still use Twitter light mode though.
All of you, drop your weapons and put your hands up!
It can't be that bright.
Oh my god.
Yes.
Oh, big mama.
Oh, somebody please help her.
Yeah, it might be bad writing, but you know...
I don't know.
I like the payoff, so I'm okay with it.
It's fun writing.
Yeah.
Oh gosh, Snake knows something up.
He's like...
Yeah, and fire!
Say fire right now.
Say fire right now!
Oh, the light's turned off.
Yeah, what about Johnny?
We know he's not doing his job.
We know someone isn't doing their job!
Excuse me!
Oh my god.
This scene is so great.
Ah!
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh!
Oh
god!
That was close.
I should have jumped out in the water.
Jump out into the water!
You can't save it!
Uh
-oh.
Die!
Bang!
I'm yes!
Yes!
Close,
Snake.
For what?
But why?
Yeah,
with her fake sympathy.
I don't think he sees anything.
Guards of the Patriots!
All this bloodshed is on your hands!
Yes!
Sorry.
Got a little heated there.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh my god!
He's sick.
He's protecting her!
This is what we mean when we say fire.
We actually commit.
We actually do the action.
You have to be more like Ocelot.
You have to be not afraid to do the thing.
Or liquid, I suppose.
Well, also Ocelot.
Let them have it.
We don't need it anymore.
It hurts!
You
didn't have to do that!
You really did not have to do that.
Evil boy!
Snake!
Ah!
Stop!
Please stop showing her face.
Oh, here it comes.
It's so quiet now.
I think lots of guys still survived though.
Or maybe not.
Maybe lots is a...
There's survivors?
Guys, we barely know...oh wait.
Oh my god.
My heart is not ready.
My heart is not ready for this!
He's too high!
He's too attractive!
Why did they make him like this?
Oh my god.
Even the sensual CPR.
Please sir!
You have to be more aggressive!
Don't just take advantage of the moment!
It's what they say.
All hot people have IBS.
Because otherwise...
Otherwise they would just be too hot.
And they need a flaw.
Oh my god.
On you?
Sir?
Yeah, I think maybe you should take off the vest, right?
Oh, Meryl!
Poopoo man was sexy.
Oh, nevermind.
First one.
Meryl!
Is this her first time seeing his face?
I wonder.
Alright.
That tastes like polluted river water.
I know, it's probably horrible.
Oh my god.
The man is...
The man should be...
This is like straight out of Final Fantasy!
I can't!
Oh my god!
Okay, can we start?
Yeah, maybe...
Oh, snake your face!
Defeat the hot buff, probably.
Unless the light is put out, the shadow cannot be erased.
So long as there is light, there is shadow.
To return everything to normal, the light must be extinguished.
Oh my god.
Almost all traces of MGS3 are gone.
Oh my monkey!
Please, time and place, Drebin!
I would be kind of mad if someone's last words to me were...
You're also gonna die.
Okay, shut up monkey!
Shut up!
He is dying.
I know, but I don't want to think about it.
Man...
115 kills.
Oopsie.
We're at 400!
Do you guys want to tell me where the...
Wait a second.
Yes, we're still on the...
Yes, we're still on the plane.
Does anyone want to tell me where the camera is?
Because one thing I also want to do is that in Shadow Moses you can do spirit photography.
And I want to do it.
You enjoy all the killing.
Kitchen, according to the wiki.
If Snake used his nano-inhibiting needle to turn off the nano, keeping Big Boss asleep, Boss could have woken up and turned that fighter.
Oh yeah, he...
He would have slithered out of there like a slug.
He would have...
Everybody would have been so grossed out that they wouldn't be able to do anything.
Cut!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Reminder for... Yes, yes.
I was about to say who was...
Chai Princess, thank you!
Who was the birthday that I missed?
Is there anything else?
Did you ever watch Metal Gear Awesome?
I did actually a long time ago watch Metal Gear Awesome.
That was the only way that I knew about Psycho Mantis' fight.
FAQing monkey.
Driven has an FAQing monkey.
Thermal goggles.
Okay, Quinn!
Happy birthday, congratu... Wait.
Am I saying it right?
I forgot the words of the sentence.
Hold on!
Yeah, I was right.
I'm sorry.
My brain is Big Boss right now.
Happy birthday, congratulations!
Happy birthday with salutations!
Happy birthday!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Quinn!
Sorry that it took me a delayed moment to sing your happy birthday.
But I did remember, even without you guys reminding me.
I was like, I gotta sing happy birthday!
But sorry this cutscene was like 5 hours long.
Okay!
Let's do...
The briefing.
Try and grab the camera.
In the kitchen.
I've been in there though.
It is a great cutscene.
Oops, I'm moving.
I love that though.
Dunkey's video on MGS lore.
I've watched quite a few videos on MGS lore so I wouldn't be able to tell you...
I can't remember.
But I might have.
Yesterday I was watching something about Tokimeki Memorial.
You know, Kojima worked on that game too.
Oh, that's weird.
I don't know.
No, she's cooking it that way.
What could it mean?
One minute.
Too cute.
She doesn't know.
It's her first time meeting someone outside, you know, when you think about it.
Oh my god, the picture of her and Naomi is up on the wall.
I don't know.
Wait a second.
Can we not get the camera because...
Because the Mark 2 is here?
But he makes the Mark 3.
Rex?
Like Metal Gear Rex?
Oh, sorry.
Are you looking, Otacon?
What?
How did nobody notice this?
I guess the stealth, right?
The video feed from the Mark 2 cuts off here.
No, Mark 2!
Rest in peace.
Get down!
I got it.
Nice.
She's making noodles.
Naomi on her way to take credit.
Nice.
Excuse me, Sunny.
Mei Ling!
It's only a matter of time before we find him.
Racks.
Something about racks being ready.
Shadow Moses.
You're still here?
Hello?
What are you doing?
I thought you were getting dialysis.
Shadow Moses.
How's the White House responding?
Put your glasses on, man.
Come on.
You can't see anything.
Peace achieved.
Today is bargain day!
No,
Snake.
No, Snake.
Unless he gains supreme authority, Liquid can't use America's nukes and ballistic missiles.
So how's he going to launch this strike?
Good question.
The U.S.
converted its nuclear arsenal to reliable replacement warheads two years ago.
RRWs.
Yes, the core of the RRWs is now completely ID controlled by the SOP system.
Sunny!
Do you guys like the riding camera?
Can you see him?
Old Snake's lines are just coughing and hacking.
Yeah, I'll let you guys see him a bit better.
That's it.
He's going to use Rex.
What?
Rex was scrapped before the Sons of the Patriot system was implemented.
Of course.
A railgun.
A railgun!
Indeed.
Rex's railgun can launch a stealth nuclear warhead into space unconstrained by the system.
In short, it's the only device they have that is able to launch a nuclear warhead.
Liquid's going to use it to kill J.D.
and deliver the coup de grace to the Patriots' reign.
Coup de grace?
Where's Rex now?
I think you know.
A long forgotten base in U.S.
territory outside the Patriots' control.
The place where Liquid made his debut.
His monument.
Off the Alaskan coast, in the Fox Archipelago.
Shadow Moses Island?
If Liquid destroys J.D.
and his GW assumes total control over the system, he'll have the world at his fingertips.
And no one will be able to stop him.
Not even the Patriots.
You are the only ones who can save us now.
Snake, I'm counting on you.
Defeat Liquid and put an end to his insurrection.
Everyone else is trying to stop Snake from doing anything except Colonel.
Everyone's trying to be like, Snake, I don't think you're really up for this.
Enough is enough, Snake.
You can't take any more of this.
I'm not dead yet.
That's not what I mean.
You can't beat Liquid.
He's got the Patriots' own control system on his side.
Not only are weapons useless, but the U.S.
military is in shambles.
And even if it weren't, Liquid's got enough men and machines to match it.
Things can't get any worse.
Face it, Snake.
We've lost.
Otacon...
We never stood a chance.
It's not about winning or losing.
We started this.
And it's our duty to finish it.
Sunny...
No!
Jack can't go.
He's not ready yet.
He needs to rest.
Let me go, Sunny.
Your dialysis isn't done yet.
Snake...
He's not ready yet.
The flapping of his bandage gets me every time.
So haphazardly put on there.
I'll be fine.
No!
This is so much to put on a little girl.
I can't even get up.
What else is will?
I'm a shadow.
One that no light will shine on.
As long as you follow me, you'll never see the day.
No, Snake!
You just put that on you.
That's what everyone else tells you.
No!
You
are both just pawns in this proxy war.
But once this is over, we will have our freedom.
Run.
I'll release you.
It's the only way I'll ever be free.
Raiden...
Five years ago...
That's not what I meant.
I've got nothing to lose.
Don't be an idiot.
You know you've got someone to protect.
Yeah, dummy dumb bozo stupid head.
It was never going to work out for me.
It even rained the day I was born.
You've got it all wrong.
You were the lightning in that rain.
You can still shine through the darkness.
The lightning.
Raiden...
Look at me.
I can't with him.
Poor Sunny.
This poor girl.
Do you see this?
Do you want this to happen to your Bishounen face?
I have no future.
In a few months, I'm going to be a weapon of mass destruction.
You...
You have a family.
I have no family.
I have nothing.
Always been alone.
Always.
Okay, you keep telling yourself that, buddy.
Baby.
Oh, sweet girl.
Yeah, he is just so pathetic, isn't he?
Shut up!
She is right there!
You're so horrible.
This is my fight.
My destiny.
Good night, little baby.
How is she going to lift this grown-ass man?
To get him back into bed.
I understand, Raiden.
Vin does this to us all the time.
What are you...
Mayling!
I got the results back.
It's official.
He's on Shadow Moses Island.
We lost Metal Gear Mark 2's signal along the way, but the ship is headed in the direction of Shadow Moses.
This is a picture of the island taken by a civilian imagery satellite.
The sea line is rising due to global warming.
Have you heard that the entire Fox Archipelago is about to slip into the ocean?
The surrounding islands have already been evacuated.
Oh my god!
Liquid's arrival there can only mean one thing.
He is going to use Rex.
That's how it looks from here.
All the Metal Gears after Rex were embedded with system IDs.
I guess it's a good thing they put...
Shadow Moses...
I guess it's a good thing they put the place on the highest island.
That was nine years ago.
In nine years they flooded?
Oh my god.
I think that's pretty severe.
How did he get back on the bed?
A forsaken island.
A haven.
I love that word.
Haven.
I'd say it's more like a forgotten island.
And it's sinking too.
Little Rex almost went to the bottom of the sea.
I thought I'd never go back.
It'll take me a while to get there.
But I'll be backing you up from aboard the Missouri.
She's the only ship in the fleet still able to move.
She's so cute.
Since it was decommissioned before the system was put in place.
And Hawaii's not that far away.
Otacon, you're not wearing your glasses anymore.
I switched to contacts.
We rendezvous at Shadow Moses.
Look at her.
The one who submits to heaven shall live.
He who defies heaven shall perish.
She's too cute.
I have to atone for my past too.
Rex is a beast born from my research.
Let's go.
Shadow Moses awaits.
Yay,
okay.
I think...
I think I stopped.
Well, yes, I'm obviously stopping here because we're into Act 4.
Is the food cold?
What food?
Oh no, the noodles, right?
But I think if I go any further...
I don't want to spoil the beginning of the...
Of the beginning of the act since it's pretty cool.
Peek next week.
I know!
Next week is...
Next week, there's so...
Oh my gosh, next week there's so much good stuff.
So much!
Act 4 is so, so good.
It's just absolute fan service.
It's the best.
I love it.
No Russian Twanting is the week after.
But, you know.
You know, there's only five acts so...
We're gonna...
We only got two more to get through the game and...
No, I can't.
I'm not ready for Act 5.
Despite already knowing Big Mama's lower dump always blows my mind.
I know, right?
I'm already crying thinking about it.
I'm thinking about...
The end of the game is just so...
Really, honestly, the last two acts is just so...
Oh my gosh, they get me hard.
No, wait, sorry.
No, what I mean is like...
They get me in the feels.
Get
me in the feels hard is what I...
I didn't mean to say it like that, please.
Don't say heart boner.
For no reason at all, could I trouble you for a new...
Oh my gosh.
People have already been asking me about a new NSFW tag.
I didn't...
I don't really check it.
And like I checked it...
Because someone recently actually and I was just like, oh wow.
There's no post in here at all.
I guess people don't use it.
It turns out that it was...
That...
I thought it was hashtag only phantom.
Yeah, apparently it's...
It's been like overrun by bots and stuff.
So, I have to change it.
I suppose.
Have it so that people stop posting as racy things in my...
In my regular art tag.
I'm like, MGSFameeto takes it to the next level.
Yeah, the patriots definitely got to the tag.
It's like...
I turned...
I didn't...
I had a hide sensitive content on on accident on Twitter.
And as soon as I turned it off and went to go check if it worked.
I was...
I wish I hadn't seen...
I wish I hadn't done that.
Because it was...
I saw so many things of IRL people that I truly wished I had never witnessed.
I was like, oh my god.
Oh my god.
So, I'll make a new one eventually.
Or something.
I don't know.
It's not on the top of my priority list.
I suppose.
Hold on.
I'm going to see if...
I'm going to hide the thing real quick.
Okay, I got the Lunar Knights main theme.
Okay, those are the two things we picked up.
Oh!
Wait, save the game.
Wait, hold on.
Okay, we can do this.
We can save.
Let's save.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, sorry.
I'm closing out again.
Sorry.
Oh yeah, because it's loading.
And I'm going to go back to the main menu.
If capture goes weird, then we hide.
It's...
Yes.
Okay, I'm glad that I hid.
Oh, wait.
Back.
Oh my gosh.
I can't go to the main menu.
Quit game.
Yes.
And then...
I know.
I remember last time I played this.
When I was just like, oh my gosh, we're going back to Shadow Moses.
I...
I was like...
Waiting until...
Sorry, it's loading the game back up.
The week after was absolute torture.
I was like...
I need...
I...
I need to play this!
I was...
Oh my gosh.
Watching you play this game made it seem like it was made for you specifically.
I think...
I think I...
I think I've warped my brain into...
Into Metal Gear, so...
Maybe I...
Maybe not made for me specifically, but you know, it's like a...
It's like a...
How do I...
I don't know how to describe it.
Like, I was molded into what this game...
Into what this game...
Is.
You know what I mean?
Maybe that's a good way to...
To phrase it.
Okay.
Well, thank you guys for more Metal Gear today!
We got the third statue.
And we got the camera.
So next fight...
We'll definitely be able to take some hot lady pictures.
And we'll do some spirit photography.
I...
I'm gonna have to try and remember...
Where they are, because there's a lot of them.
I probably won't get all of them.
I might enlist some help...
From you guys.
But we'll see.
I'm gonna go watch the video again.
I invented a tongue twister.
I really wanted you to try.
Say...
I love you, Jolly.
I love you...
I love...
I love you, Jolly.
I love you...
I love...
I love you, Jolly...
Johnny.
I love...
I love you, Jolly.
I can't do it.
I...
I love you, Jolly.
You adopted MGS.
I was born into MGS.
Molded by...
Johnny.
The Merrell tongue twister.
What do you mean it worked?
You're trying to...
Get me to sound stupid?
I love you...
Is I love you.
I love you.
Oh, I guess I kind of hear it.
I have to pronounce...
Or enunciate more.
I love you.
You guys are so...
You guys...
Konami flashbang.
Bless your heart, Minto.
I have no heart.
Otsumito everybody!
Thank you for Act 3!
And we'll do Act 4 next week!
Otsumito!
Thank you everybody!
Have a good night!
Bye bye!
You can still hear me.
Oh my gosh.
Later boss.
Later!
See you when I see you.
Did I go sideways for a second?
I have to turn off my PS3.
These are the behind the scenes that I do after the stream.
You're still here?
I'm closing out the stream.
This is it?
Oh shoot, I let the song repeat.
I got a DM.
What's happening?